hand sanitizers are really handy
especially when soap and running water
aren't within reach but are they worth
using more often or should you try and
avoid them altogether hand sanitizers
contain ingredients like alcohol which
is often at 70% concentration that works
to kill microbes one left on the skin
for 30 seconds or longer it's able to
kill 99.9% of bacteria present and even
certain types of viruses like influenza
A the sanitizer breaks open the cell
membranes of these bacteria or the
envelopes of viruses although they're
ineffective against for releasing
bacteria and viruses without envelope
there are also non alcohol-based
sanitizers using other ingredients but
depending on their combination may just
be bacteriostatic meaning they prevent
bacterial reproduction of course anyone
who's used sanitizer knows that it
simply spreads grime and dirt around so
soap and water are necessary in these
cases to clean up but in the absence of
visible dirt which works better a 2009
Australian study had vaccinated hospital
workers contaminate their hands with
live influenza A virus and had some of
them wash their hands with regular soap
and water for 40 seconds followed by
paper towel drying while some of their
hands with 61.5% ethanol sanitizer for
20 seconds and others used a combination
of alcohol and antibacterials
the remaining group was the control and
did nothing as expected
the control group had the most viral DNA
present but the group with the least
viral DNA was the soap and water group
despite the fact that sanitizer can
destroy germs soap and water actually
removes them from the hands and comes
out as the superior method of infection
control but does the temperature of the
water matter turns out that while hot
water can kill bacteria this only
happens at 99.9 8 degrees Celsius which
would burn your skin so save some energy
and wash with cold water of course
soap can also be antibacterial and these
often contain triclosan so is that even
more effective well it turns out that
they're typically way below the
effective 1% concentration required to
cause bacterial side effects and studies
from around the world have shown these
soaps to be no better than regular soap
furthermore triclosan is washed down the
drain and ends up in lakes and rivers
in fact it's one of the top ten
contaminates found in all American
rivers bio accumulating in many marine
organisms like dolphins even more
troubling is that triclosan has been
linked to promoting antibiotic
resistance in bacteria in a process
called cross resistance as bacteria
become resistant to triclosan they
simultaneously evolved to resist the
effects of other antibiotics even though
they haven't been exposed to them well
this doesn't mean using antibacterial
soap will render your antibiotics
ineffective the study highlights the
possibility of unnecessary antibacterial
usage potentially leading to superbugs
of course a common misconception is that
hand sanitizer causes bacterial
resistance as well which in most cases
it doesn't as they primarily use alcohol
as their active ingredients but some
brands of hand sanitizer do include
antibacterial ingredients like triclosan
so it's important to be aware at the end
of the day your best bet is always using
regular soap and washing with cold water
saebom sanitizer for sink less
situations and avoiding antibacterial
soaps for the sake of your health the
environment and future generations but
is it truly better to be clean in the
first place we debate between being
clean or dirty in our new a stop stop
video that you can click here and look
at the hygiene hypothesis and other
studies to figure out the best way to
live your life from a sanitary
perspective don't forget to subscribe
for more weekly science videos every
Thursday we'll see you next week
[Music]